Thank you for watching!
Oh, so here I was kind of like nervous. I didn't really know what to expect because like it's my first time doing something like this and because of the rumors, I don't have a lot like pressure on me since it isn't as big as like a competition venue.
So after I ready up for any kind of competition or whenever I start my poomsae, I always try to like strictly focus on my poomsae and not think of anything else.
So it makes it easier for myself so I don't have to suddenly forget things or feel weak whenever I start my poomsae.
So whenever I do this section of six, I felt that I was like a little rushed so a lot of my power went away because of how fast I was going.
So at this moment, because I realized I was going a little too fast at the beginning,
I tried to slow down and improve my overall power and presentation.
I think that's what it's going to look like.
And if I get tired, I'll go back to the beginning.
But I think it's still going to be a little scary.
But it's still going to be a little scary.
It's going to be a little scary.
As you can see, your pattern is scored based on the number 10.
So out of 10 is your mark.
As you can see, it's split up into two parts.
We have our accuracy and our presentation of the set.
So we'll start off with the accuracy first.
So your accuracy is actually scored from...
I already know how this works, Dr. Moster.
Yeah, you can move forward.
You were actually marked true.
So where the judges actually mark you from,
it's actually was above average.
You might get scored a 1.4 for now.
So your rhythm was only about average.
It wasn't amazing.
It might be just a 1.3.
But let's say you didn't shout very loud.
So...
Your expression of energy, your average was 1.3.
It might drop to, say, let's say a 1.0.
So...
Okay, so...
Sam did our 15 mistakes, very small mistakes.
At these numbers, after the judges are finished scoring,
you would get, for this pattern, a 6.2.
Which is actually very good.
So...
Pretty good.
For Hannah,
he saw a couple more mistakes than I did.
So maybe this one would be a little bit lower.
It might be a 5 point something.
Another judge on the other side,
they scored a little bit higher.
So we get the three numbers,
and then we average that as well.
So I hope this helped you guys.
So make sure you enjoy your pool deck competition.
And anytime...
Make sure, obviously, you...
Make sure you enjoy your pool deck competition.
So, minor errors.
We cannot pause your video this time.
So we can...
Do it real time.
While you're watching your...
Performance.
Okay.
Okay, and then after the...